[Music]
[Applause]
for example beyonce sent out this tweet
and it says uh people may hate my baby's
name blue ivy but wait till they meet
our next baby green algae
mitt romney sent out this tweet the
worst thing about driving in the
summertime when i open the sunroof the
dog falls in
[Laughter]
made you happy
tan mom everybody knows about tan mom
yeah hey folks we didn't do the joke yet
that's just her
10 mom tweeted this job offers keep
pouring in tomorrow i start my first day
as an entry-level horse saddle
that's exciting good that's good that's
good if you can get it president obama
tweeted this thought i'd interrupt this
comedy sketch to remind you that i
killed osama bin laden
[Music]
chris christie tweeted this i've lost
147 pounds so if anyone finds my missing
bag of 588 quarter pounders please email
chomp master general at new jersey dot
gvt
chomp now
a tan mom sent out another tweet let's
see what it is yeah got another job
offer as a pair of ups shorts
she's getting a lot of job offers it
really is she's very talented uh george
w bush sent out this tweet tell me again
why i don't get to use the big airplane
uh larry king tweeted this when i was a
kid the expression was what will jesus
do
you see he's been alive for thousands of
years that's the thing about him yeah he
sure is dark in our book in our book
bruce jenner tweeted this score just
bought my original face on ebay
oh that's lucky
[Applause]
tan mo i can't believe she said
another one yeah another job i'm the
newest member of the real housewives of
chernobyl
wow
and finally president obama just tweeted
this i approve of gay marriage conan
andy enjoy your new life together
hashtag and i kill though some of them
lobby
there you go
[Applause]
[Music]